yeah I am live but the phone numbers are
gonna come on Twitter hit me up with
your number on I want to get just for
the dare this is the phone number and
you're gonna start seeing numbers coming
on Twitter like phone numbers stream at
some point see that
what is up YouTube Facebook what do we
got Facebook YouTube Facebook what first
in line community on Facebook love that
Facebook overall Facebook and YouTube
there that's the blog that needs no
Instagram
awesome cool
oh we posted 24/7 good good what's caleb
doing amazing sharing that where's Caleb
getting rained on all right we're live
right all right everybody's watching we
just oh this video is catching just
doing well people like it right it's
funny do we change it to cynics can we
take that we may never change that guy
name happen to be Gary yeah and you
haven't happen to go viral well we found
something was it was this thing was
going by roll over all all right about
to call some peeps is Instagram live on
about to be all right are you get phone
numbers let's go
just take them give them to me ready I
got you 201 Jersey got it to 506 eight
five nine everybody's watching I'm just
going to move to answer questions I'm
just gonna answer the [ __ ] questions
that's what I'm about to do and people
that are part of my new tips lesson
platform in the beta this is Gary
Vaynerchuk who's this Oh what up Coby
how you doing man - goose head Thank You
Man what's your question my question to
you is like how do you know when to
trust your trust your head versus
trusting your gut trust your gut why you
say that will you [ __ ] asked me a
question bro I gave you an answer
because I trust your gut every time okay
because I live life around regrets and I
think more people regret not trusting
their gut than trusting their head plus
you're young as [ __ ] and the younger you
are the more you trust your gut because
your heads filled with nan
from parents and society and school and
it actually makes you go on defense in
your 20s and 30s when you should be on
[ __ ] offense is that a better answer
thank you I'm joking you don't need to
be sorry I just I just the reason the
answer gut is I really believe the
answer is gut so yeah I'm in the
military right now so I was like I don't
know what you know it's one of those
things where it's like I don't either
first and think or whatever trust your
prisoners yeah thanks I miss you so I
listen to a lot of here at your podcast
and I'm hearing your your videos thank
you dude thank you yeah my dad
introduced me so you saw I was like
super excited about it when I outside I
was expected to comment bad that's how
we do it coke I wish you well man thank
you
all right good let's keep going and II
[Music]
love them this would they were good
right name if the ladies was hilarious
are we clipping that [ __ ] Jose call
that Jose calls a fifteen-minute IG TV
banger it's so ridiculous
that's what I want to like like wait for
it in the end that's like they that's
the way you title that one Mike it's
Gary Vaynerchuk yeah hey are you but you
had like a second because I was calling
and you probably assumed that that was
it right or do you think like somebody's
cranking you or something well that's
what's up man what can answer for you
and I I'm 39 years old and I've been
doing it for a long time
very young but I've only last couple of
years really embrace the online social
media platforms and I mean I've been on
Facebook forever and all that kind of
[ __ ] I've always I was always like I'm
just gonna make records and I was feel
so stupid like I get it now but like
this is just the world we live in
so I've been consuming your content for
a couple years and and and and I'm in
that like making making making content
documenting the process that kind of
thing yes and the thing is I have three
projects and there I think is it there's
my solo project there's me with my best
friend we have a pulp
duo and then we also have a four-piece
band okay and and so I'm trying to
figure out if I should lean into you
like branding myself as the guy who has
these three projects or should I just
focus on like my skip my solo project
it's called dear mr. henshawe it's like
kind of my my alter-ego Tom and I play
around with my feet and stuff like that
and so it's like yes question let me ask
you a question straight up your no
[ __ ]
okay which one do you feel best about
like you like the most and feel has the
most upside like net net best of these
three things which wouldn't you feel
best about what so so the interesting
thing is like the band the four piece
band tons of guns it is that's what I
feel best about but there's three other
guys involved we live in three three
different places yeah but there's and
that's the answer to your question just
so you know yeah I have less control
over that and with my photo project I
why do you feel bad about that because
best doesn't mean what you think is
furthest along right now best means
net-net right yeah you can't like the
Florida for peace is best and then you
start then the next things coming out of
your mouth were four reasons why not so
maybe you thought maybe that's the
furthest along from a short-term success
standpoint but maybe it's not the best
right yeah it's gotta be this little
project that's we need to get into
that's we the question for everybody
who's got things like that is not what's
part of this a lot like people like this
one thing's making 50k this one thing's
a K this one thing I'm losing money on
but do you feel best about aka you like
the most but and you think you could be
successful because what you might hate
you might like the 50k one the most but
you might not think it has the most
upside or me like this like what people
don't understand is we settle too often
and what we need to move in on is the
thing that checks as many of the boxes
as possible when you're faced with
choices and you don't know you go with
the one that if all works out
everybody goes with defense they have
three things in front of them they're
like what can go wrong I go the other
way of these three things if they all
went perfect which would I be most happy
about the middle one that one do you
understand now you balance that with
delusion you may like you know your solo
alter-ego project the most because you
don't get feedback from anybody else you
might be delusional yeah yeah no that's
true
I mean if you get more versatility at
music with a four-piece band and a lot
more collaboration the fact you like
when you went into I don't have as much
control different things that's a that's
a pretty logical and practical thing and
so I think look I think the thing about
doing something for a long time and now
being 39 is it's incredible your
youngest [ __ ] you also sounds like 20
years of data that says okay here's what
it is you're 20 years in you've got to
decide what are we doing here like at 17
it's about I'm gonna [ __ ] make it and
fame at 39 do you still feel that is
this now about loving the game loving
the process yeah is this about
I could one of the things that most
people understand about me is I just
couldn't do anything else if I was right
if I was one one-thousandth of six as
successful I could just couldn't do any
look at me like with my hundredths of an
inch of free time I want a garage sale
yeah I don't have any other [ __ ] gear
this isn't about options this is about
happiness yeah I'm still doing it
because I can't not do it
can't good
somebody else you know I mean Otto
hustle up do what I got I got it I got
it go just to be clear when I say when I
say control with the band I I don't mean
that like an array of control I mean
literally like I like if somebody offers
us a gig we have to check with three
other guys I followed you I wasn't I
didn't think you wanted to be the
ringleader I thought that Barney might
have a flat tire
yeah Lenny I just want to play I just
want to make a video every day and play
a show every you know every week and hit
2 or 5 pounds a year and stuff want to
play play play so why don't you leave
into all of them yeah and I know I've
been doing that lately but I'm in terms
of branding you think I should just be
like yeah bling in the three different
Instagram accounts just switching back
with more than doing it all yeah all
right or post them all on one I mean I
got fun yeah I got an Instagram account
where you don't know if the video who's
gonna be about me like flipping a four
dollar teddy bear or like having a
[ __ ] conversation with the CEO
Verizon right all right yeah yeah
totally
just be you cool see ya getting back to
be you go ahead any I'm ready like by
the way everybody who's watching like
the only advantage you have is you
there's so much content at this point
like you playing some character or
trying to compete in some vanilla game
is no shot like the only thing you have
is your subtle ridiculousness we're now
in the game of edges it is the weirdness
Sara like the fact that you love peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches is like a
variable now hello
hey Sara it's Gary Vaynerchuk hi how are
you I'm super well how are you I'm doing
fantastic thank you what can I answer
for you okay and I stopped following up
with people I thought did you hear my
customer and I really want to
get back on it and I want to come on why
this why did that happen personal stuff
then also like I just I think you got
what I got burn out that makes sense
that's awesome
I think burnouts amazing and normal okay
listen to me and listen to me good and
this is gonna be important for everybody
why don't we judging ourselves about
yesterday
good you got burnt out which is clearly
what you need it cuz your burnout has
fired you up to get back to it yeah yeah
like why is it okay like like why is it
okay to like well actually this is not
okay look by the way I am I've had a
very kind of like burnt out first five
months on my fitness and health
afterthought four and a half years of
killing it like I made a decision that I
kind of looked how much it cost me to
travel these guys around the world and
finally decided you know what I should I
want to pay twenty three hundred dollars
for a workout so I decided this year
yeah yeah anyway nevertheless like like
kind of kind of sudden you know what
Jordan you don't even travel with me
this year like whatever and I'd
completely lost my way
like I'm super fired I got real lucky
because he was wrapping up and literally
in a week Mike comes back and it's gonna
be Mike for three months Jordan for
three months Mike for three months
Jordan for three months and so like
mainly because Mike was coming back it
bought me a little more time so like
I've like gone hardcore drilled it for
four and a half months and I've
absolutely not been on my game this year
and I've really not been on my game the
last six to eight weeks and like okay
I'm definitely like carrying that extra
like eight pounds that I don't feel good
about it's on my mind I'm sharing with
you now but like I'm not open judging
that like like what well like I'll just
get that like I know I'm gonna get going
again and it'll be awesome
right and like I just you know like
don't judge your burnout so like what
would you do to look forward like how
you with your surveys and be like hey
Mullins I had it call them okay do what
I'm doing with you
yeah man this was incredible this was
like it's celebrational because now I
want to call everybody that's exactly
like call every [ __ ] person how many
customers you got um gosh not a whole
lot
give me the [ __ ] answer I mean I
don't know probably like 5500 where are
you right now what state I'm in here all
right East Coast on alright by tomorrow
night this time you should call every
single person okay I'm telling you right
now I'm super intrigued for you to do
that oh we have to call Victoria or
whatever Virginia go find her number so
you really uh you need to call them all
by this time tomorrow I'm being dead
serious
happen you know what happy Memorial Day
hope you have a great weekend hope you
have a great weekend and you know no not
you I'm telling you what to tell that I
mean I believe you have a nice little
Morial Day weekend - and by the way you
want have a really great Memorial Day
wait to see what you feel like waking up
Saturday morning after you call these 50
people in the next 24 hours yeah
seriously I don't feel like I really do
it right now listen you know what's
crazy about this in the way that I
answered it this morning was the first
workout I had that was kind of something
in a little while and it was [ __ ]
you know you start to lose your way you
know like little like cardio stuff jump
Ropin treadmill and I felt of me I feel
great like you listen to me everybody
and you and me you can feel terrible for
ninety three months in a row and execute
properly today and start the process
feeling great you know amazing that is
that is it like it doesn't count you
know life is more like boxing than it is
like basketball basketball there's a
record you're like 60 and 20 you know
boxing is you win this fight you win you
can be 30 and oh and you lose this fight
you're back to zero like right right you
can win the next fight like like like so
like just win today's fight like call
everybody you better call at least five
people tonight
yeah you better you're gonna cool
something right now
okay all right I did you I love you bye
yeah these are [ __ ] amazed I'm so
fired up about this God wait what's your
number
Victoria it's Victoria fortunate your
hobbies get confused sorry ending a job
they are when are these dropping well
June tell people freaking networking a
20th global India to cuz India's de Sol
so that means India India's freaking out
about this Turkey's going nuts guys have
a pronouncing some man's name wrong I
know you're ducking me Virginia oh
saying what you have researching a
hauser of great house dog training I am
currently working with a client right
now if you could please leave your name
phone number and best trying to contact
you I will reach out to you as soon as
possible
or if you're interested in scheduling a
consultation please go to great house
dogs tree I've been saying that she's
mad
but when you're not you know thank you
and have a good day
Virginia its Gary call me back
I called her the next day you with me
right yeah
yo Dave no way yeah David it's Gary
get the [ __ ] Adam I'm staying
I apologize real estate yo there's not
even gonna call me well no [ __ ] I'm not
gonna call you I'm like 8,000 [ __ ]
numbers the odds were very low you
should go play the lotto
yeah I know I should I'm gonna go buy
one right now let's go what can I answer
for yo so I wanted to ask you man
I love all your videos thank you really
push me thank I know you d rock Bevin
everyone awesome spitfyre every day man
I definitely bit in his body grabbing
some water but I am no like I love
everything that you say everything that
you saying is absolutely true but I just
want to like what you say just stop
doing what you're doing and go do you
got it that's what I want to do I wanna
go how that how do I do that
how do I do that because figure Alec
every figure out why you're not doing
it's either ocean it's either insecurity
or complacency yeah or confusion there's
a million reasons why it could be so
like what's your hot take what's the
honest truth like what do you what do
you want to be doing what are we talking
about here well like what I want to do
is pretty much like what do you rock and
Batman are doing you want to film yes
you know so on it and everything why
don't you go work for somebody for free
for a year okay
all right now now you can do what the
rockin diamond did it go work from go
work for free slash minimum wage for a
year go find somebody who's a winner and
a proven winner ready that you resonate
with personality-wise okay
hang up the phone right now and DM a
hundred people that you look up to and
say I want to work for minimum wage to
film you like D rock and babban filmed
Gary B control copy control pace to a
hundred people okay I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it for us and then I'm gonna
like should I do that to like help now
in my office just now on Team Gary just
shook his head not thinking you're gonna
do it okay why do you think he thinks
that go ahead and do it right now well
yeah like I think I think the thing that
like here's my question why why wouldn't
you and what else would you be doing
like what like spit it to me truthfully
what would happen normally now in the
way that you like i apprec-- I can see
you're about to open up which I'm
excited what would normally happen now
you'd hang up
uh-huh and what would happen normally
okay normally and I'm being super dude
I'm dead-ass what are we doing here if
you want to be happy let me [ __ ] help
you but I need you to [ __ ] tell me
the truth okay all right so straight up
I'm not even joking with you I'll
probably go on YouTube right now and
watch your videos and probably be like
dude this guy's saying the truth but you
know what I'll be doing they're probably
watching Hulu or Netflix right now and
just be [ __ ] watching just my own
show okay you know we're insulted
because what I expect you to do right
after this is hang up and [ __ ] hit up
all your boys and be like yo I just
[ __ ] talked to Gary Vee I write for
real but seriously but seriously why are
you not motivated for action why are you
just consuming chin that's the thing
like I don't get it like I was so
motivated like keep talking and I would
be been writing films and then I would
add up why I just stopped okay
are you are you fulfilled like yep
that's what I want to know like
are you happy yes like what are you
doing oh hell no I'm not happy like okay
I just like got me off like last year
from my job at a bank okay
and I just been working side jobs and
you know and now like I've been doing
that flip like eBay flipped life may
over 500 dollars from boots I got for
free
okay and yeah now I got a job at a
clinic and I get paid like what like 10
dollars an hour which is [ __ ] so you
know it's something yeah listen
do you think you're are you insecure do
you think you can't do what babbit
indie-rock do like do you deep down deep
deep down know that you can't film I
feel like I like I have the potential to
do it I just you're just not sure where
are you you're not sure yeah like I
wanna stick a nice are you just not sure
like you you think you might but you're
not sure right which makes sense I'm
just curious yeah okay like with me like
I don't really want to film from my
phone I want to film from an actual
camera so I think to look good for it to
look good for me to like it and not just
for me but to everyone at you know like
everyone to like it as well but the
[ __ ] iPhones are good that's true
though I think some dope-ass pics for my
iPhone not gonna lie look I think listen
to me the camera quality is the quickest
L for somebody who's full of [ __ ] okay
and I'm saying that with love and I
think you can tell ya listen to me
there's some reason you don't want to do
yeah
are you like historically is hard work
like not fun like shoot it to me like
tell me okay dude not gonna lie on them
people don't believe me but I whatever
it is you like you didn't gonna do it
I'll do it and I don't care about hard
work man I honestly I think your work
then what about judgment like peer
pressure like getting judged oh yeah you
that 100% like okay like and I'm being
serious because I want to do my own
thing like like I said film being movies
do it doing me something with that and
then my mom's like like that's just
fantasy and I even told her how is it
fantasy there's like thousands of people
doing it right now how is that fantasy
it's not Holly
boy it is hard probably
but you can do it do you live do you
live with your mom yeah with my mom move
out okay first sure man no Joe no no no
no let's talk about her oh because we're
going through this this is working for
me how are you gonna move out well I
mean the things that are going right I
mean what I was telling her too I just
want to show everything from my room as
much as I can okay get all that money
good and get out and when she's angry
and honestly Gary might otherwise I got
like it a 2001 Buick Century still runs
to this day people are like dude was
like what the hell is that type of car
but let me tell ya I keep up with that
thing and that thing has down me
everywhere love it so and and I have
been like using it for a you know going
garage sale yeah listen to me no one you
told your mom you're gonna sell
everything and be out what did she say
she just she just like looked at me kind
of like well she wants me to do it like
she's on both sides of course she's on
she's a parent yeah yeah right so what
did she say this time yeah like for real
I'm not gonna lie she wants me to do my
own thing like she she wants me to do
that but she wants me to have like a
good stable job you know like you like
the suit I like actual government job
but it's kind of like I told her to I
want to be happy and do my own thing
listen doesn't believe in it listen to
me okay you have to stop talking to her
okay you have to stop talking to
everybody sell all that [ __ ]
find a friend on Craigslist or find a
high school friend or I don't know
[ __ ] know like like move out stop
talking okay like like I don't
understand what we're doing here like
you're talking about it she wants you to
she she doesn't believe in your dream
she wants you to [ __ ] get a safe job
because that's her framework you don't
want to so don't move the [ __ ] out move
the [ __ ] out and work for somebody for
10 bucks an hour filming them there you
go I already listed that I live in like
in a small town outside of San Antonio
Texas good if I can find some San
Antonio [ __ ] real estate person or
some [ __ ] entrepreneur there at least
37 of those [ __ ] look up to
babban indie rock and mean
[ __ ] go yeah Poirot dunno but I don't
wanna play like like I really just want
you to do it yeah okay
like why haven't you moved out yet
that's what I've been telling myself too
I graduated 17th at 17 so how the hell
am I still here in this [ __ ] like
small-ass town like I want to reach you
know like I don't know like I feel are
you scared of I'm not really scared of
you're very careful worth a knee that's
what people were think you live with
your mom people are saying [ __ ] now
that's true so you know that you cross
that chasm bro stop [ __ ] making
pretend you cross the chasm you look at
their mom people are saying [ __ ] right
right who's laughing like exactly and
honestly do that like I don't know man
like it's just like I hate like living
in this small town because that's give
us a [ __ ] bus okay and just get out
if I sleep no stay in your mom's house
forever
yes get the [ __ ] out okay okay well I
think so like I mean you need you need
to sleep somewhere like maybe you'll
sleep in your [ __ ] 2001 [ __ ] car
yeah why not I mean it's quite logical
if it is [ __ ] cause like people like
if you want to do it do it you're
worried about what your mom thinks
you're worried about what other people
think
let me let me save you time your mom
thinks you're a [ __ ] full of [ __ ]
because you're still staying in the
house and all you do is talk and all
your friends think you're a [ __ ]
loser cuz you live with your mom
exactly okay so we're where we left what
are we scared of now okay
everything you're scared up already
happened there you go everyone's
[ __ ] on you already
you've been [ __ ] on there's no [ __ ] left
yeah the thing that scares you happened
yeah uh-huh you understand the thing
you're scared of happened you're just
bullshitting yourself that it didn't
happen and that's keeping you from
getting happy yes sure you know they
don't even want to do [ __ ]
like the way we want that's fine bro
religion society neighbor that's that's
fine too listen listen I have nothing
but empathy and compassion religion
households the culture society social
media your parents your [ __ ] uncle
your grandparents wait to your
grandparents die before you do that then
above the [ __ ] MIT the [ __ ] whole
thing is that bro yeah you're right I
know I'm right I really really think I'm
right on this and I think the most
interesting part is the thing you're
scared of already happened dude I'm not
gonna lie man
remember last year I went to LA amasai
and said why don't you stay with me I'm
listening
like actually think why don't you stay
with me and that's the place I always
wanted to live with my leg talk the only
thing that stopped me was my friend
okay what about him or her I the only
thing is because I don't want him to go
along that I just don't want him to go
home by himself back to his home home
where it to San Antonio yeah San Antonio
at the time you guys were there together
right cuz what was gonna happen he was
gonna get punched in the face when he
walked in no I just know like I mean
he's married and everything but like him
and I just went on the trip together cuz
I always wanted to go to LA yeah that
sounds worse to me than the iPhone
camera story dude you're [ __ ] scared
do you understand me you're [ __ ]
scared and the part that I'm most
excited about is the thing you're scared
of already [ __ ] happened you know the
best thing that ever happens to a young
male they get punched in the [ __ ]
face physically cuz then they're never
scared of it again they actually know
what it is yeah you ever been punched in
the [ __ ] face Andy that's good
yeah Matty yeah it is Doug
a big elbow you got me - [ __ ] head
let me tell you
listen regret doing that listen to me
listen to me you're scared right about
something that already happened
alright Gary tell me now you're alive
and I'm gonna get out of here and I'm
gonna start DNA right now not gonna
light once we get off this phone call
I'm gonna start again at some
photographers nope you're gonna start
DMing entrepreneurs in real estate agent
Ritter okay who want and you say I want
to film you for 10 bucks an hour okay
but now I want you to DM people that
live in Los Angeles okay I'm gonna do it
tell me why you're not gonna do it after
we hang up tell me what's actually gonna
happen that's what are you made I'm
asking you I'm asking you what's gonna
I'm being listen I'm not doing this for
show or contact we're here like I can
get content why I content everything I'm
here because I really am trying to
figure out I'm playing here
we're playing angles here you know like
what why won't you do that like why
won't that happen when we hang up
hearing like tell me by yeah yes
honestly because because my mom's are
gonna be like shut the [ __ ] up if you're
not listen to me a wife you listen to me
your mom is [ __ ] your [ __ ] up and
you're [ __ ] your [ __ ] up you need to
get the [ __ ] out of there okay you
understand that right yeah no like on
some real [ __ ] yeah
you're right you're right cuz she had
that stuff like most of my life she just
believed like you'd let her mess it up
bro you messed up
you let her mess it up she's 49% of the
equation you're 51 yeah a lot of people
have [ __ ] up mom's half yeah some of
them did something about it you're using
it as your [ __ ] excuse
alright alright the second you stop
blaming your mom even though she is
wrong like you notice where I did
they're like you're understanding
they're both true she is wrong until you
take 100% responsibility for being in
that [ __ ] house doing nothing you're
doing nothing it's super easy to blame
your mom yeah it's your fault you know
what's [ __ ] up yeah so let's go okay
I'm really yeah listen to me bro you got
to get the [ __ ] out of that house I will
listen you need to get the [ __ ] out of
that house bro okay look you get the
[ __ ] out of that house bro okay living
your [ __ ] friends basement even
though his wife will be pissed
move with your getup go - [ __ ] [ __ ] diem
and go to the airport and fly to your
aunt's house dude not gonna lie I'm
really am thinking about getting one-way
ticket to LA mother's love you I mean I
got my doesn't thank you going to Alex
just made a face Alex who's [ __ ] keeps
it straight she just she said no you're
not
Lebanon beings I'm telling you because
we're live on here wanna watch dog Gary
aren't you what's your Twitter handle
ready press it I want you to live on
Twitter right now and go to the airport
Oh what's your venmo I'm gonna bend
though you $1,000 right now and I want
you to like that look at me hey what I
mean listen to me
I heard him listen to me listen me we're
gonna make a deal right now
I will venmo you $1,000 right now but
you have to live scream your ass going
to [ __ ] the airport using it and
going to Los Angeles
okay okay water so let's um we're gonna
recap right now if I owe you one
what's that a first thing I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna set up a bad mocha though
you have a pen red and you got a PayPal
yes I have PayPal let's go okay damn I'm
an extra 500 Andy okay oh it only means
a one way one way Andy what time's the
flight - you bet that I says I promise
you I'm gonna go to my car fill it up
and you know what I'm just gonna tell my
buddies go drop
the airport yeah you don't need that
[ __ ] car no more okay I'm gonna do it
straight up I'm gonna start packing
right now not gonna lie I believe you
hold on I'm gonna I want to see what
flight we're putting you on what x in x
in San Antonio right now okay it's
actually seven forty one right now all
right what do we got any there's a he's
not gonna be able make that 55
we got OAM what about 855 850 no we got
you bro nonstop Thursday May 23rd LAX
let's go Southwest let's go what's
what's your pick up with Tyler where's
my pay pal what's your pay pal bro okay
you want you all right on my paypal for
us I'm getting dressed right now I hear
you I'm excited I'm leaving them about
change your [ __ ] life dude oh you
better call your what I'm wearing my
Mazda Jersey in there let's go okay all
right so here's my here's my paypal and
Tyler's ready here's the PayPal okay
okay okay and okay if it's sunny Jim 5s
oh and why okay good okay
oh and my good Jay I am Jan sunny Jim
yeah fine the number five I know five
okay at yahoo.com yeah no I'm kidding
I'm kidding all right how much is that
flight
you got an 855 bro you're gonna have to
move okay
I'm already gonna I believe you
I'm sending you a thousand [ __ ]
dollars I think the flights like 140 so
no you could [ __ ] take an uber to the
[ __ ] for season
tonight and that lying [ __ ] go now
real quick where's it what's his Twitter
bro here's the key though because I'll
ruin her life I'll find some Russian
mafia people take you out I need I don't
know I might be sort of the flights sold
out no honestly I'm we're canceling the
whole thing now that you did that the
ending no no he's going on a flight
tonight I don't give up this
[ __ ] us asleep in the airport
livestream the whole time he's leaving
his [ __ ] house right now
well I'm sandy I'm so sorry I apologize
but I'm being dead serious I'm already
packing right now hey bro listen to me
Tyler just hit the button you got $1,000
in your PayPal for me right now down
here it's rial oh my god okay okay
what okay yeah that's the thing listen
to me but you're welcome so much but
listen to me
okay I need you to go live on [ __ ]
Twitter how do you go okay
you've gone okay I'm Google and when you
get to the airport there's no flight
you'll figure it out the days of relying
on your mother are over it is now Google
ok Google is your mother you understand
yeah you don't have an answer you go to
[ __ ] Google that's right that's right
all right
taking your shoes with me Gary that's a
good idea
all right it's out it's David lh9 7:08
for everybody who's watching right now
cuz we're all gonna watch him do this
yeah dude I'm already leaving to the
airport not gonna lie Marty packing
that's fine
David lh9 708 ok he's a traveler who's
never left his mom's [ __ ] home hey
how wouldn't I talk to you right now of
course not dude this one turned out to
be better yeah and by the way you
couldn't stay in LA you had to go back
to San Antonio
so you can walk up into his house with
his [ __ ] money yo good I'd rather get
away and you stayed away dick what do
you mean stay rather stay you were
staying and you live in LA now David you
live in [ __ ] away you're calling your
aunt of course yeah yeah well let me
tell her what a real surprise is gonna
be David the amount of people in LA
right now they're gonna be hitting you
up on Twitter telling you that you could
stay with them yo I believe you were
family now yep
David lh9 708 is his Twitter handle he's
about to go live he's gonna figure it
out cuz his new mother's name is Google
bro what are you doing
well I can't see you [ __ ] live
streaming on Twitter all I see is your
traveler uh David listen me you need to
stop pack well actually pack because I
want you to get the airport you don't
think there's a plane in San Antonio huh
we're about the place yeah what David's
gonna do you know hey there's about to
have some billionaire [ __ ] fly in
from your mother is Google what you're
asking Andy to become your mother I need
you to become your mother you and Google
do you understand we're not finding [ __ ]
for you I give you [ __ ] thousand
dollars yeah the practice day I'm just
kind of like already gonna get the
thousand bucks and already gonna like
use it I have to buy a ticket
let's go now one thing I'm impressed
with is March 16th a week ago I know a
couple months ago I do like they found
that Hasbro you know GI Joe tank $4 and
sold it for 1060 right that's good yo
you should have seen me man
what the second kind of lips - no first
time I went to LA you came a week later
I'm like this [ __ ] man what the hell
but hey this is even better
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] house situation to
move to LA and change your life that
would have been better than the one
second selfie we took at the [ __ ]
case with store virginias calling bro I
gotta go Virginia's calling see ya hello
hey Darius Virginia it's good to hear
from you Virginia how are you how are
you I'm great I'm just checking in yeah
yeah you caught me in the middle of a
session I was signing a contract with a
family good for you you caught me in a
session of giving it some kid in San
Antonio would have [ __ ] up mom a
thousand dollars to move to Los Angeles
and change his life you know was that me
did we quit or no tell me the truth no I
didn't quit Carrie I understand to
become close how long did the high from
the call I'm quitting last where do we
get how far did we get I mean honestly
the the high from the call lasted a few
hours and don't get me wrong I had it
off the high of quitting what's up we
didn't get to talk about during the call
was I already have a plan for an out
like I have an end date like July 10th
I'm putting in my two-weeks and July
24th I'm done okay I'll call you back
what you like
that sounds perfect to me real nice
you too man take care hello hello it's
Gary what's up Dana Adam I'm super well
how are you that's good does your fiance
okay with that I love it
what can I help you guys with well you
helped us every day or meet more on the
ing 2002 you and your platform and we
were literally
name-dropping you today at dinner at
truth food kitchen at the Boca Town
Center to our lovely waitress Alexa and
she's a awesome snack and I'm like hey
you know Gary Vaynerchuk is and my
favorite right
yes usually we're talking about Vegas
then I thought you were you asked me was
I saying it right now saying yes so the
money and I'm like well don't you know
what Gary would say he would say Anne
[Laughter]
and how did she take that he was off to
a great moment she's gonna follow me on
Instagram and I told her about another
friend of mine that's influencer in a
different room than yours
yeah and it's just anything I have your
lavender she's a female version I wear
to the airport and some kids saw like a
those are Gary diesel it yeah that's
also at we're already subscribers to
your empathy wine you're right
thank you you're welcome
guys are very sweet what can i what can
I answer something for you guys because
you're just flattering me which is I'm
beautiful but I want to bring you value
I want to be a part of your team in some
way if you ever need something in
Florida we're here and already we have
this high spread you're on one say when
you say your possible what is well yes
thank you for the right word and I never
really want anything Baphomet others
that trying to be a part of making the
world more with charity love and I'm
very sweet
what's nice sweet I'm so glad I got you
guys on on the phone and since I'm here
and I'm pleased this whole Garrity world
I'm gonna Central you a question please
hood you know a lot of what you say to
some people seems matter-of-fact
but at the same time there's always that
mental block well yeah I kind of get
what he's saying but you know I can't do
that because of x and y and z y as
always that robot so for those that have
that robot being built with you I don't
know if that's for me how do you respond
to that and say I'm working for you it's
for everybody yeah so it's a great
question I think listen the two words
that scare me the most are butt and
because when they consume my content
right those to be words scare the [ __ ]
out of me and it's because they scare me
because I know that it's grounded in
insecurity and I need to figure out the
reason I consistently put out so much
content is that I know the only way for
me to actually achieve impact is a scary
level of consistency and creativity in
perpetuity so what do I say to them I'll
see you tomorrow
right right right cuz you never know
what version of the same thing you've
always been saying teamed up with the
right moment in time leads to the first
moment of action and that right on point
yeah it's just you know like I can't be
ideological about it I know that we're
all on different paths
I'm just I'm ambition I'm ambitious on
actually having this impact and legacy
thus I have to be focused on consistency
you know it's really meta like what I'm
actually up to and trying to achieve I'm
actually doing which is what I'm telling
everybody else to do
I'm staying patient I'm staying
consistent yeah state of course I get it
I get it I actually had to reset my
facebook password so I'm not even on the
line right now I'm trying to don't worry
it's being recorded you'll be able to
watch it eating some popcorn later okay
all right all right guys take care
you're welcome you bye bye
well going out of here Virginia is still
working what's that yeah I hate a lot of
work what button because ma'am but I
can't do it because yep Brian it is true
no you know I quote you what because you
have five followers and five is my
favorite number it's real bro Wow
oh I only wait time but I'll so much for
everything you know give um so I let you
know basic real quick thanks for easy on
reentry cells on yet and the reason why
I'm telling that because I was in such a
crossroad cuz I'm I worked in corporate
job you know and it's good do it for my
parents and you know and he was talk
about reselling and from the death day
on to now it's been crazy with eBay and
Amazon I mean I want you to work a
little differently now so with a little
more leverage on your side yeah let me
yeah exactly more leverage and this
my life makes me super happy bro listen
the flip life is very very very [ __ ]
real and I've got my version of it which
is like fun and exciting but Weezy and
others are showing people and there's
many other great voices out there like
showing people scalable [ __ ] and
honestly bro
I like I made do one episode of trash
talk where I just buy everything at
every garage sale and actually just show
people how actually ludicrous it is
because almost everything that's worth
more money I'm just doing the stuff that
gets me up going like my like its dude I
left $150 Yankee jacket right next to
the Jets jacket yeah people saw it like
on purpose and I read all the comments
like three people saw it yeah no I saw
it I saw it I didn't comment but I
thought yeah but I wanna resume like I'm
not scared you're mad but um yeah but
anyways but anyways I wanted it actually
real quick down so it's actually what
happened was I was I'm doing reselling
on the side and I've been using that
money to pretty much put that money into
my family's business and so what we do
is a family restaurant and being his
restaurant my parents have a really big
restaurant in Tampa and they downsize in
a small very very small area yes and
essentially we've been doing a lot of
piece of marketing yep and I remember
having a lot of spikes on my dad's oh
how are you gonna believe in yada yada
ya um and obviously now he's like what
one person wasn't one the news channel
actually has to get on TV
now he's like wow um we shouldn't do it
because I'm waiting there watching TV
the whole time it's been flipped his
mind has been flip but now I'm doing
more with influencer marketing just
because you've been talking about how
under president and it's so real I tend
to be real yeah and and right because I
don't talk about [ __ ] until I've proven
it to myself
I'm not out here guessing I'm not out
here trying to give any you [ __ ] a
demo to say I'm wrong I'm talking about
[ __ ] that I already [ __ ] did yes yeah
no you're right
and the thing is it's been working
vertically it's been okay so I know one
thing that I want to ask you is
basically with our rest
and tend to um it's such a small area
right how do you know which followers I
guess I guess is very tactical here but
how you know what followers or
influencers importance it's worth
messaging because I've been dealing with
a lot of influencer that you could tell
they're fake followers and because it's
not like an online business where you
just hit up anybody that is within that
field yet there's a little bit smaller
smaller radius so what would you your
suggestions be go after alpha moms in an
area don't go after influencers go after
normal people that actually live in the
area because all their followers are
from the area right even what if it's
under a thousand and all that would you
rather have somebody who has four
hundred thirty followers but they happen
to be two hundred residents that live
close to your restaurant or would you
rather have said here's ten million
followers and only sixteen or in that
area yes yeah they're right yeah cool
well yeah I don't know I don't yeah
that's all thinking but just to make
sure great yeah well thanks Gary oh you
love it yeah love you man funny weird
rare jet [ __ ] in a garage so I want it
oh well oh you got it that's actually
great call to arms
anybody who's flipping garage saling if
you happen to find some crazy ass [ __ ]
normal people actually in the area these
all in follows along right really [ __ ] I
feel like a it's over
you got it I [ __ ] could do this all
day for the rest of my [ __ ] life the
person that raises you is the key to
[ __ ] life in a way that you can't
imagine and then the other key to life
is the outside voice that penetrates you
whether pro or just pro or con to that
and that's like I'm doing right like
that's what makes it so exciting like
you know what I think about what I'm up
to
it's more like being a rock band in the
70s or an early
pop band like you get the kids at 14 15
16 and you're like the first thing they
free but it was all like sex drugs and
rock like it's all back stuff so I'm
trying to like you know like how do I do
this
hey Josh Gary life is great Josh how are
you
SuperDuper what can help you
amen so my girlfriend wanted to know
what's the true value of an internship
uh the value is the people that you
actually meet there that later on put
you on it has nothing to do with
learning anything because you won't and
you kind Ellis limit phrase it's it's
highly unlikely you'll learn a whole lot
you may get SuperDuper lucky and find
the right kind of company let's call 20%
which is a nice number where you do
learn something but even if you're
learning even like I'm watching my team
where I think people are really learning
if I just like think about it like you
can learn like I'm looking at all the
faces like you're learning quite a bit
in the first 60 days but man there's a
lot to learn you know what I mean I'm
saying like you can get a little what is
disproportionately valuable is the
relationships gosh a thousand percent
bro life is about people god I really
appreciated
dynomutt take care like Josh came in
boom boom boom boom let's go caught with
the off-speed pitch
that's Brian again
what's everyone saying it's good people
like it
well how many followers did
what's-his-name get he went from 16 to
only had 500 you know 1116 116 116
anyone got to a thousand followers ever
probably in his [ __ ] bed bugs that
[ __ ] better be going to the
airport he's not live yet
whoa Paulo it's Gary B no [ __ ] way
yes sir no yes I'm using two folds right
now
want to contact you and want to watch
your dream double fisted and I would
just watch it I was out watching David
LA yes and he's not eight not hopping
there's no live or anything
you're [ __ ] pissed right I'm Ben cuz
you're saying there [ __ ] if I
would have gotten that shine I'd be by
the shell I was waiting for $1,000 then
someone's gonna call him to call it that
if someone can live with him and kind of
move life but he's not you're upset with
David yeah but I have a question yes I
would i watch your videos in there
there's times we say that like people
that are I have given has been given to
them like materialistic yes are not
their disadvantage they are and I feel
like I'm on that side good okay I'm
gonna be spoiled but then I just felt
like my life is a spoiled you know yeah
you're spoiled and my question is how do
I remove right though stop taking [ __ ]
from the bottom stop taking [ __ ] yeah
that's what's happening cuz I 15 you're
in high school right now and it's all my
dad dad
from now on don't give me anything give
me advice don't give me anything that
proudly brother are looking hard
dude I'm real I'm really I'm really
admire you do you know how hard that is
there's no cookie for me Paulo it's when
you are live
people will take [ __ ] from you but no
matter what is it in your head he can't
keep it away you can take your card you
can burn it down people can steal from
you buddy
feel the knowledge that's in your head
that's a good that's a great point by
your dad - hey now I don't want uh I
don't have to see where I'm going at
colleges I'm not pursuing money I'm
pursuing the freedom of not working 9:00
to 5:00 okay but in order to do that I
need to work hard no [ __ ] very good I
like everything coming out of your mouth
but this times where I do watch the
video then when I when I'm done I don't
have the motivation but if I do I lose
it or maybe it's because that what
you're saying is I'm spoiled in like I
mean I'm one of turns days I need to
find where I'm by myself and that's why
I decided to UM move in by myself and
with my dog like how are you guys how
are you paying for that apartment I'm
gonna do a whole two coats I already
applied
I live in next to you that it's on up
north in New York and I'm graduating
high school about three weeks but right
now I'm working as a part-time job but
as soon as I graduate I'm gonna work a
two full-time job
then when I come home I'm gonna hustle
and look for something that I really
bored that's amazing dude I'm super
[ __ ] but I like you
cuz you think you get where you are you
need to do the full-time doubt that
there's no other way well if you don't
go to college if you don't go to college
and get the kind of degree that gives
you leverage to get the kind of job you
want what's gonna end up at like like I
could do a career nurse then use that do
you want me and I don't know if I want
to do that you don't want to do that I
know but what you weigh these days I
won't know until you try right cuz my my
dad was when I told my dad called you're
wasting a year I'm like dad I watched
this guy like hell even if I wait let's
say I wasted a year it's not a waste of
and now I know that I at least I tried I
didn't like wait like 40 years then I
blamed my dad that I thought he stopped
me from doing what
even if I fail I'd rather fails and not
do it Paulo you're gonna make me want to
do this for the rest of my life like
everyone coming in your mouth it's me
I'm really impressed
I hate regret Gary good meter break you
can't pay regret like I'm with you on
that one man I feel like you're Gary Vee
and I'm Paulo no no bro you don't even
though I'm shaking and I bet just like I
was once quad to you then the danger of
a blew up that I like holy [ __ ] this is
New York but what can I do question can
I ask you a question
go ahead is your dad impressed with the
things and thoughts that no he loved it
but he told me Paulo and he told me all
the time what are you doing with the 24
hours I'm like yes I understand I'm on
my phone he's right this there's 24
hours there's eight hours of me in
school then I worked a part-time job so
between my I leave a school from 12
afternoon then from 4:30 to 8 I work
every day impressed I told my dad that I
want to I want to pay for my car I want
to pay for my bills I want to pay for
everything cuz I don't want to be that
because you've given me just we moved
from Philippines and just by doing that
cuz there's no way if I was in
Philippines right now working there's no
way I could get a car but because he was
there and he worked hard and that he
brought us to America I have the
opportunity to actually do what I want
to do hello I [ __ ] believe in you I
don't wants to say I love every [ __ ]
thing that's come out like there's one
thing that I hate in my life where okay
I have I could do it but for some reason
they're either like so being comfortable
that's why I wanna move in to my old -
after that there's no help from my mom
there's also my dad my kids will be guys
I can't [ __ ] around like I have this
move I have to do or I'm gonna fail
that's great so enjoy your next three
weeks of vacation and then get the
[ __ ] work that's how I thought about
school at this point I was like this is
vacation let me suck it all that life
about to go for 80 years
realize right now it was like oh I'm
quoting myself
Oh
start work hard when I you're about to
find out here's the good news if you go
and do this and it's on you two jobs to
pay rent and you start [ __ ] around
and go to one job and watch [ __ ] konami
I'm doing that I have let go on my phone
oh my god them up like Gary oh [ __ ] I
felt like Winnie the Pooh 1997 like with
your addiction I bought I bought it for
like through selling it for $4 I was
like can I buy small little I made for a
ballet they gave you all of them and I
was selling for $20 on let go I'm
[ __ ] proud of you bro so what
happened you bought those 12 Whitney's
Cooper gallery and sold them for 240 but
not only that I thought each of them for
$20 and all sold them all
yes and not only that I would tell them
I said I live in I miss you and they
were like I'm in Albany I was like if
you want to pick it up
it's no if you want me to bring it to
you at $15 anything with a $15.00 and I
would get $35 for just me buying one
dollar of a mug in like a Saturday
morning
I understand Gary I get hello yeah I'm
here look and I think your idea feedback
oh sorry it's not feedback bro it's
[ __ ] pride I'm [ __ ] happy as [ __ ]
about you all right like this will be a
new regulator yes you can
oh my god wait but how do I kill that
good that won't seem like you killed
that like procrastination or I kill that
like being comfortable because you're
about to find your bed it sounds like
you've a very specific plan you got
three weeks of vacation and you're gonna
try to kill you Bobby cool I'm Chloe
[ __ ] on vacation stick with me okay so
three weeks of school aka vacation enjoy
the [ __ ] out of it get anything out of
your mind get leggett it put a lay it
all on the fields now that great great
name for years because say something huh
the girl that you've liked for the last
three years in high school and haven't
said [ __ ] to go say something wrong
broke up but I'm fine I move on alright
respect on respect if it's I've been mad
at this point cuz it's not you're not
gonna help me if I'm on my own
let's go on your own as good bro it's
good I mean I've been stopping like my
friends are like Paulo why are you
picking with your face I'm like I'd
rather have one that's actually good
that I've hunted in to see what's up man
and not actually knows them like go [ __ ]
yourself your prerogative
I like both yeah yes but you're telling
me is just the weight just use that
three what three weeks I'm good with
everything I've just heard the maturity
at 17 the level of conversation eighteen
level of conversation with your dad
you're [ __ ] flipping you're about to
get two [ __ ] jobs to have yeah you
and your [ __ ] dog I'm [ __ ] pumped
bro ain't not good I was like I feel
because my dog my dad doesn't want the
dog so take the [ __ ] dog to the dog
though I have to get apartment that has
a dog that's fine they have those I know
I know I know I know but bro oh my god I
can't believe you I'd be like
copy-pasting like my phone number for
the last an hour dude will you trick the
indie good job
oh yeah anything you're doing good job
all right bro good luck oh my god yes
you made my day holy [ __ ] oh yes a good
night guys you too bye bye I like that
kid it's crazy to hear the difference of
something that's right like I'm just
looking at you guys like the difference
between somebody that's seeing it and
the one that's not seeing it and you can
see it man that was a super mature
conversation that felt really good to me
hello Corey this is Gary Vaynerchuk holy
[ __ ] yes sir hi hi how are you getting
it how are you super good this is great
getting like wasn't really two years now
and super cool talk to you thank you
what can I help you
so I'm starting this job in like two or
three weeks and I really been upset
for a long time that's kind of like how
people work one of the things I've
noticed a lot is like managers tend to
like micromanage how you work and they
tend to focus less on like what let's
people be in there but like be in their
zone and what really motivates them do
words I think so more agree more how do
I change people's minds and how do I get
managers to kind of back off people and
kind of let them live in their space I'm
learning with new job at Dell and so
like you communicate it to them it's
highly unlikely they'll listen to you
and you move on when you don't find the
manager that you like how do I be that
person for other people and how do I
because I'm kind of going to that base
to where I want to do that manage your
gut you're going into a place where you
don't have the leverage so you've got to
be thoughtful about that right your
ideology is right your ability to
execute on that ideology doesn't exist
upfront unless you persuasive in your
communication to a manager as a new
employee so how long should I like shut
up and kind of I just build up leverage
for a few months and kind of work
towards that that's a strategy okay
cuz if you come in hot on day one
telling the managers what the [ __ ] yeah
it's not gonna work out it sure isn't
the number one mistake in our society
right now is people are yelling at each
other on social media trying to convince
those people to see the world the way
that they see it yeah yeah yeah you know
you you know you you just can't come in
with that level of audacity it on your
first day you're gonna hot take by like
good news David's live on Twitter what
uh does that make sense to you yeah I
got good so I just need to like kind of
calm down and keep my head down figure
things out and build up some levers for
more listen and pay attention to the pay
attention to the main
you might find somebody that actually
sees the world the same way you do and
you lean into that person okay I got it
see where I'm going
yeah I appreciate your demeanor because
I'm glad you were listening because it
makes sense when I point it out to you
right yeah I guess that's kind of been
my can under it for a long time is I
have like a bunch of these ideas and I
think it comes from watching my my dad
try to do this and bang his head against
the wall for the last 15 years this kind
of made me want to it kills me on the
inside when people go to work and
they're passionate about what they do
and they can't do it and I've seen that
Thank You Connor I got I got news for
you
this isn't the Soviet Union yeah
somebody that goes to work and is upset
with their manager can go to another
place yeah we need to get off of some of
this ideology hey guys yeah it's it's
important it's important this is an
important conversation because you're a
good kid I like what you're talking
about but sometimes we go too far and if
we don't stay in the middle we're gonna
lose do you understand yeah like it
makes me sad about a lot of things but
people are in control you're right
people do that but I don't miss and tell
me all sorts of [ __ ] I'm like life's
about alternatives like if this place is
so [ __ ] up go work somewhere else yeah
I I was born in the Soviet Union where
they told you where the [ __ ] he worked
and if you didn't they [ __ ] shot you
in the face
it's [ __ ] America yeah you don't like
delgo with Microsoft
I got it so what you do is you either
but I love where you're coming from so
either you stay quiet build leverage get
thoughtful or when you see somebody
who's also passionate about putting
players in a position to succeed you you
get cozy up to them and let them be a
mentor yeah cool I have like one more
question
like I is this something where I should
I do this like when I'm passionate about
I really like working with other people
haven't you go into each are you going
into HR I'm not going in HR I didn't
I've never really liked seeing myself in
HR and I didn't know that's like
something that a chart kind of does it
is a good HR place does okay so you
think I should kind of like look into HR
if I have that kind of attitude and
those kind of like aspiration if you can
find some place like Vayner where they
put HR culture and people on a pedestal
and it's not about just joggling around
dollars and you know yeah well I'd be
pretty stoked become work for you one
day but you can email me right now
brother you can email them right now
email me I mean we're building out our
HR like I like where your head's at
where we're at because I Gary and later
Gary at vaynermedia comm put in the
title you'll be on the [ __ ] week it
was vaynermedia okay all right this kids
on [ __ ] live let's go he's probably
gonna be was it probably like at about
an hour so maybe less hopefully again
is 100% true no I cannot believe it
but yes it is 100% true I love y'all and
I can't believe this has happened to me
right now and yes I don't care what
anyone says I am believing what Gary Vee
says I love y'all yes bro it is your
[ __ ] time just change of
people's [ __ ] lives
right like it's just so crazy look like
this is so real like it's such a special
time look what we just did do you
understand what's happening in the world
everybody's looking for bad and this
stuff is happening every day versions of
this is happening
this kid was [ __ ] like do you
understand like actually what it means
to change somebody's life like it's just
so surreal it's just so [ __ ] surreal
like if the internet didn't come along I
would appeal 8,000 [ __ ] liquor stores
would have been [ __ ] super successful
what a [ __ ] sold it and bought the
Jets everybody would have thought it was
the best and it wouldn't have been
anywhere close to his interesting of a
life
this kid was laying in his [ __ ] up
mom's house and Santa is in the car
right now flying to Los Angeles and
people are pinging left and right for
him to be there video person the dudes
could be living his dream what'd he want
he was making 10 bucks an hour that's
some plate he's gonna beat em up it
doesn't 12 vote gives me 5 and 9
whatever he's literally 48 hours
Memorial Day in a week everything he
dreamed about an hour before I went live
on a day that I didn't need to come back
here at all still [ __ ] a little [ __ ]
up for my crazy travel fought for it
this is how the world works fought for
it right like you know like took a
stressful call outside watch these three
[ __ ] outside doing who knows what I
was like smiling and made me happy and
then got off that call you
yeah you three we're outside just I was
also I was like watch it like what do
they do it was fun I was like on this
[ __ ] up call then ran up here and
[ __ ] one live and she just [ __ ]
kids life so awesome and he tell
everybody you were standing [ __ ] you
know how he had he got a shot same [ __ ]
just like this right I didn't think
about that and eat like we all change
each other's lives so fun so how did you
get your job I used to read every email
it took me time to those go you I was
like [ __ ] I don't write the best email a
salaries never gonna respond you didn't
respond in the first week ago and I was
like that's it today's three months
later at midnight I love that nobody
believes me about anything please say
your name a favor one it's like you
[ __ ] how did you money to focus you
say you made no money
how'd you [ __ ] have money to invest in
Twitter and Facebook like [ __ ] lived
in a [ __ ] apartment and save money
I mean $43,000 a year and made xi and
saved 11,000 sitting foot soon on samman
seen on yeah see nam soon on how do you
say it so done [ __ ] community from
[ __ ] to wine library the liquor store
for a year work the [ __ ] minimum wage
he wanted it like everybody like I love
when people some people here like uh you
know like you know they come in they do
the resin thing whatever you know like
after like you know you watch cuz like
you got some of you were still in others
like I watch right and some people like
at three three or six that bird you know
day one school he like fire you know
week three and I'm like see not [ __ ]
commuted from [ __ ] to New Jersey and
walked to wine library for a year at
minimum wage
you know there's this is what is
interesting it's it's a one big game of
entitlement if your ambitions are big
like what like I'm always curious of
like what's the person's ambition it's
not for everybody but like if you want
it so but like you know like I don't
know I'm fascinated by it
cuz I really eight [ __ ] I did it
lived it you know it's so fun to give
advice you lived it makes it fun makes
it fun
I never feel weird I never feel weird I
say hello nekkid I really really did it
Gary really did it
hello hello hi Gary hello how are you I
am awesome because you called me I well
I guess I did Jacqueline so um I own a
sugar 30 business that I run out of my
house I have four kids
one of them has special needs and gets
therapy all the time and so I do all of
my work when they're asleep my husband
has a job but we wanted me to be able to
stay home but I really like selling
cookies there's a lot of fun everybody
loves cookies who doesn't know cookie
right I love you I'm gonna buy so many
of your cookies like you're opening
scent like Jacqueline you have to
understand like I love you so much like
I'm literally right before I call you
talking about entitlement you're a
mother of four building a business when
everybody goes to sleep you have a
special needs child and people are yummy
like a baby
what the [ __ ] like how do I live in
Brooklyn if at 14 bucks an hour like
move live with a roommate to me don't
buy for ya and final it is like them I
think it's I mean you make me yeah I
need those you're my one validating
sugar cookie into thing Gary's right
ready for this
so it's Tudor House cookies right okay
so right now yeah you have three
thousand six hundred ninety six
followers three thousand six hundred
ninety six followers
everybody's watching right now if you've
ever gotten anything for me in any shape
or form that's been good I want you to
go to Tudor House cookies tea you do ha
yes cookies
- you do our house cookies Tudor House
cookies they was around my house right
now this is pretty awesome
are you drinking of dr. pepper not at
the moment
but you might earlier I do love dr.
pepper it's so good dr. pepper is gonna
be in heaven Gary it's so good good your
cookies look insanely amazing thank you
and they taste good I want that taking
sugar being Houston they look good and
they taste good
come on everybody else not following I
don't know what [ __ ] okay you pick up
like 200 followers quick okay so my
question is I actually had a meeting
with a chicken earmark month ago yes
because she is like head of sales and
stuff at Reliant Stadium which is a huge
saltating here and she's bitching we
can't buy we can't buy yet I'm not
allowed to [ __ ] because I don't have a
commercial kitchen what
so not pet so every state has different
laws about people that make out of their
house and Texas is stupid and you can't
ship them if you make them out of your
house if you make them out of a
commercial kitchen you can do it over
the hell you want okay so that makes it
a lot harder to get business because I
can't just sell my in a job idea
whatever yeah you're up to 43 hundred
followers alright so you can [ __ ]
right
a commercial kitchen for like a day and
[ __ ] bang them out well you have to
get a million dollar insurance policy
and how much does that call a couple
thousand dollars I'll buy it for you you
don't you don't have to do that well if
you went to that would be awesome
oh my god okay so okay so this is my
idea on how I can stay home with my kids
but also make a [ __ ] ton of money so I
met with her earmark I met with this
chick right toe and she said would you
ever be interested in doing live demos
at conventions like OTC which is in
Houston every year it's pretty huge to
go and I said absolutely no she said
okay make up a price sheet and send it
to me so I did some research I've never
done anything like this before but I did
some research on what they normally pay
for decorated cookies and all that kind
of stuff I sent her a credit sheet she
said it looked good I look at the detail
we get back you she never got back to me
I email her once a like she's got more
time I tell people he mailed me all the
time I told the kid that emailed me
about HR I might not reply I mean that's
a tear and it looks like what's that
what we try I'm trying real hard out
here it's not my intent at the moment
but we're drinking out of a [ __ ] fire
hose I don't want somebody walking
around earth saying Gary Vee told me to
email him and then he didn't email me it
[ __ ] up my brand I'm trying to answer
every time but who the [ __ ] knows Tyler
[ __ ] deletes it by accident right ty
it happens Malick's you believe that
[ __ ] by accident right cuz you're a
human I knew [ __ ] wrong every minute so
give us a [ __ ] that she hasn't gotten
back to you hit her up 14 more times or
if not [ __ ]
well so I emailed her once a week the
last three weeks you didn't respond so I
was like okay forget it so but now I
like every time I check so now I want to
try and like hit up some other people
like maybe the ladies that run all the
food stuff at like Georgia Brown
Convention Center which is five minutes
from my house check what I'm doing a
business together and I just get a
kitchen in Texas and we just [ __ ]
domini let's freaking
do it Gary okay let's do it okay yeah I
think what you're doing is real I mean I
assume other people make good-looking
sugar cookies these just look good and I
just like you mainly because you posted
I love Jesus but I curse a little what I
do that that I mean I curse on this call
but I do also love Jesus so that's
accurate I really really really like
what you're doing I think you really
have talent it's really really really
good thank you so much Gary that's
awesome I'm gonna say no I told Andy I
tweeted him about like 50 times and well
not really that much home I was gonna
send y'all cookies so I'm gonna send
y'all some cookies because well you
better send it just gave me like [ __ ]
3000 followers in like 16 seconds
actually what are we started 3,600 you
picked up a thousand [ __ ] followers
already that freakin awesome Jason
doesn't even have a thousand followers
[Laughter]
all right Jack Gary at vaynermedia comm
emailed me let's see if we can figure
something out yes definitely thank you
so much Gary you're welcome the ones
from Florida yeah the one 401 or like it
was okay go ahead okay thanks
Zenon sin' on non it's the non part and
I want to do man I have this non man
issue seen on your non he's a non good
guy that's how a minister remembers I'm
a little old to see not yo hey what's
going on with it this is Gary Vaynerchuk
Oh get the [ __ ] out of here yeah bro I
got you how are you oh [ __ ] I'm doing
why are you super well man what can I
answer for you a little background I'm
27 I work in real big mess in Cevallos
apartment building and I'm just trying
to start like all the marketing
planning for our company and stuff gonna
start do it myself and I guess two-part
question one should I focus on myself or
do it through the company you're now -
how do I get bigger on YouTube and and
Facebook cause I'm short on there
yourself and slowly okay so definitely
focus on yourself and if you I wouldn't
overly worried about getting big on
YouTube and Facebook for the sake of
getting big what you need to focus on
everybody focuses on getting big more
followers they need to focus on making
content that brings value to people the
reason I always win is I only think
about the customer I never think what's
in it for me
ever ever ever I've never thought about
how many followers do I have how many
followers am I gonna get never ever ever
that's why I don't celebrate when I get
1 million followers or 20 thousand
followers or whatever it is right but I
guess I think part of the course you
don't have that in my mind everybody
like I understand it like I think the so
the answer is make content that brings
value to people yeah and we're starting
to do that like we host like a nice
healthy we just posted videos like 2
hours long and you see when I start
chopping it up and putting it on
different so I guess it's more like I
understand you know kind of the I just
cuz I work more and do stuff on
Instagram and a little bit on LinkedIn
and I kind of see the different
subtleties between the two of them yep
is there any different subtleties that
you would change between going towards
Facebook and YouTube is it more long
form than that way of talking like yes
how does that play out yep the answer is
both you get more long for new options
on both of them and the audiences are
different you you know Facebook is
skewing older by the second right
YouTube is super broad you could target
ads on Facebook in your general area and
you know and an age group so yeah okay
cool can I can I ask them or you can ask
one more quick question but real quick
when I looked at your your uh-oh it's
not him okay
keep going bro yeah wanted to do is
start doing like Facebook and Instagram
ads and obviously you know we raise
money from investor to find out worth
accredited guy and we have to obviously
you know there's some very areas with
SEC and stuff like that and you have to
make sure we're not stepping over
boundaries what are some ways that you
would get people to your website without
you know we can't say hey I've got this
investment opportunity you know we've
talked about doing like webinars like
yeah offerings and stuff like that then
these things besides the candidates or
they see and you guys shouldn't render
member education and entertainment I've
heard that one before yet it really
works bro I'll give you another one that
is a little more tangible you can send
out an email a tweet an Instagram post a
facebook like you hit up everybody
everybody right that you have and you
ask and spend one day calling all of
them and asking them for what kind of
content do they want okay
like one of the reasons I'm successful
is I do research I read all my comments
and I'm good at synthesizing data to be
a creative a lot of people never even
get into the part of listening I hear ya
i I definitely try to do that like I'm
always asking people like we literally
just had our you know last night light
on the hours in a hotel we had like 40
people out there okay you know I'm
always asking people like how do you
like you what do you think stuff like
that and you gotta ask them what do they
want on the under website or what do
they want the more content yeah that's
the thing feel like we always send out
email like we always focus it around one
subject like oh what you guys want to
talk about next and like we just did it
on a be ever in life you also can use
corner trends and type in words from
your industry and see if anything's
poppin so I played with that a little
bit I've got like a running corner
called Google Ads just to like
understand it a little bit for the
company so then okay so you know to say
you know what it sounds like the deficit
is potentially right now ideas so yeah
I'm definitely like I'm not like a
marketing background or design I'm
trying to pick up the pieces I don't
know yeah familiar or not
eventually outsource it to either I love
that the next step one I do is have like
a couple VA start doing like most video
production and stuff like that and then
eventually bring on someone full-time to
do video and heading into it's not my
strongpoint it's taking up a [ __ ] ton of
my pie right now and really really a
waste of my time because it's not my
strength well it's not a waste because I
do like the context building but I like
that you're aware that there's a passing
of the baton you know what I mean
yeah and I think you might have learned
a lot of what you could do believe it or
not as this may sound it sounds like the
ideas part to your point this is where
somebody creative matters one of things
that took me a long time to realize in
my team and my agency and then just kind
of like only over the last two years I'm
like wait a minute why this feels so
easy is because I'm creative but that
was not something that I really leaned
into it was something I took for granted
because I leaned in more towards I'm a
businessman right and I think that's why
we're trying like we're literally on the
cusp of starting a podcast and I want to
start leaning into other people where we
also want to do like with the with the
media stuff off to do like a roundtable
type thing where you bring out any
borders yeah we go ahead and keep going
I like home go keep going in that I like
we go with it keep going okay the pieces
right good luck is he live yet students
literally okay cool right
it's neat his best friend is going with
him leaving his wife night Lois this is
Gary Vaynerchuk so Gary I do it super
well you blessed man blessed what can I
help you with um so I I moved over here
in New York from New Jersey and got into
sports thank God and
and man it's a grind that they told me
from the beginning and I'm through it I
just my biggest fear right now is not to
burn out you know I mean I worked more
than 60 hours a week and that's just the
way you know business is sports is you
preach it and you gotta work your ass
off but you're worried people yeah what
are you feeling I come back home after a
homestand I just come back home after a
game and I'm just not tired and then
head back yeah it'll do destroyed well
what do you want what do you want to
happen you want to balance it a little
more a little bit but then I feel like I
wouldn't be able to you know get that
one be able to get to my next step life
has no cost right yeah your understand
right are you like like are you
physically tired or mentally tired I
think it's more mentally since I mean
I'm I'm usually not on the field like
I'm not really doing this thing
physically yeah mmhmm yeah are you
feeling are you feeling pressure from
anybody significant other parents
friends um I mean just a regular
management but that's just normal that's
just you know I should say oh that's
poor things no no are you telling are
you feeling pressure from anybody in
your life to be homework not really not
yeah I think that's more to come are you
are you potentially being impatient how
do you may do that well I mean you know
I think the way you can measure it is do
you feel antsy like I'm getting burnt
out and crap I'm not getting what I
deserve
have you said I have it am I not getting
recognized the way I deserve or have any
of those kind of things come into your
mind a little bit
not grades I kind of like that all good
I'm not yeah that would be a sign how
long you've been there about to go for a
year do you feel confident that you are
going to get recognized or or at least
if you put in these years leverage to go
to another ballclub um I think little by
little since there is more than 60 other
people I was in the sales floor so I
think that will come is just are you
good might be
are you good at it I think I am number
two right now in my own Department a
little bother to pull them out but at
the end a that's just my biggest fear
it's like one of these days I'm just
going to do this is too much and walk
out that what I've never been that
remoter straight on the college what's
what's the fear of that good Courtney
who gives a [ __ ] if you do that you
worried that your resume is gonna say
you're only in a place for nine months
and they're gonna ask I know it's a good
question that's what we're hanging did
you question free do you ever get burned
down not really but that's that's but it
could happen and if it does I broke you
wanna hear something crazy
secretly I would love to wake up
tomorrow make a video be like yo I'm out
burned out SIA because it would help a
lot of people yeah bro when you don't
care about other people's opinions you
don't care like I just by going by the
Patriots on everybody yeah
I'm kidding that won't add it's like I'm
not fear I don't fear it to burn out I'm
pretty self-aware I have been doing
selling and flipping and since I was six
so like I there's a part of me that kind
of feels like this is some Tony Bennett
[ __ ] you know what I mean like maybe
eight and [ __ ] with Gaga you know and so
but but if not then not and what what's
gonna happen people go on social media
be like see you all [ __ ] looked up to
Gary Vee he burnt out see you think I
give a [ __ ] what Johnny pants 37 thinks
about my burnout damn Yeah right
I know so this so you worrying about one
day you're just gonna wake up and be
like [ __ ] this place I'm out for what so
good reset it's the theme of tonight's
come up a second time
oh and your burnout move on Britney
that's awesome
what I mean by that is if we stop
calling it burning out and called it I
changed my mind
I think it would have less stigma and
yeah I think we've made it into this
failure thing burning out too awesome I
changed my [ __ ] mind
yeah I've got moving man damn good man
it makes me happy like all of a sudden
it's not scary and once it's not scary
it has no power yeah that's why I love
pulleys [ __ ] man
once the bully gets punched in the face
I'm trying bro
it cuz it's simple [ __ ] but sometimes
you don't see from the angles sometimes
it takes a random call at 9:44 on a
Thursday night in late May and you hear
something and it just changes the way
you walk in tomorrow yeah more uh I
don't really care about what might have
II just gotta roll with it what's gonna
happen is good let me with you like
what's gonna happen you know like buy
some sports bye bye sports cards bro all
right I like that have you been hearing
what I've been saying man there's money
to be made in next two years on cards
yeah I gotta leave but I mean everyone
out right I mean do you have $100 of
course well not of course but like
awesome like you follow baseball oh yeah
yeah go buy some Bowman rookie cards
I'll give you a hot take right now this
[ __ ] right here Jordan Adams
mm-hmm he's a rookie Jordan Adams Jo are
dy n Adams okay I gave him love the
other day I started talking to it he hit
me up I've talked to him on DM
I like this kids game man I think it's
good be a real player and he's
inexpensive you could buy Jordan Adam
cards buy a bunch of them flip them they
probably just went up I'm do I reach you
I like I like what you said my man
that's a thoughtful answer go do
homework bro I'm telling around go on
eBay completed items go go look at
baseball America's top 100 prospect list
know what you know do a side hustle
there's a lot of people about to make a
hundred thousand dollars a year in
profit flipping cards listening to me
it's gonna happen mark my words it
wouldn't what it does to me I'll what
you gonna say I'm say I was the guy
good luck bro
Iraqi yo sorry uh this burnout thing
like what like who once you eliminate
the judgment of people around your
failure I love when people try to say
[ __ ] about my failure I'm like what
about you
he's right like seriously though
especially parents especially siblings
nobody's remotely close to perfect it
could be I do think I think it's a
really thoughtful question I do think
burnout sometimes is that what people
manifest impatience into and they think
they're burnt out but what it was really
was entitlement and it's actually them
like like wow
kicking it's great you know but other
times it's mental burnout you know like
there's a lot of people that burn and
burn out again look I think we have to
we have to we have to we have to be very
careful when we talk about these things
there's people have mental health issues
versus people that put over stress on
themselves versus moms Scituate yeah he
like he's got a mom situation now he's
on a plane he's at like you know like so
you know when I talk about these things
like I don't have all the context I
don't want anybody to ever think to take
my that were that Paulo kid was taking
some nice time very blindly like I was
good you know you I'm worried about that
stuff but but yeah man I mean that dude
is not burnt out that dude is just
worried about the ramifications if he
doesn't like his job quit nobody's
looking at your [ __ ] resume they
don't give a [ __ ] if you work somewhere
for three months blame it on we've got a
crazy boss people do anyway fire to [ __ ]
a load of people that suck [ __ ] that
blame it on me so fun night
I like the random calling like I feel
like I like it also with like the last
couple times
so empathy you know just like this
[ __ ] find people million dollar
insurance and [ __ ]
please leave your message for seven
seven two four one eight six eight five
eight are you [ __ ] up hello hello
hello hello
I like who's this oh yeah
how are you I'm very well who's this
my name is Amir I'm the Keith from
Melvin I mean it's great to see you
oh no oh my give you a random coconut
silly in the light and I was like no
one's picking up my I felt like Krystal
number time at home you want dinner
yeah I love it I'm late you wake man how
are you
things are super well what can I help
you with Tyler called him once remember
wait question yes um basically I it's
hard at the minute
yeah um I'm end it I've met 50 uh I mean
it's a bit of money and I wanna apply my
knowledge you have other people sell
their house okay
okay I'm gonna secured a business name
okay and I'm going I'm sorry I remove it
yeah don't let it cool I'm oh my god Amy
I got good news
it doesn't matter what it's called yeah
you do you know why I'm saying that
visit the product food doesn't really
matter what the name is right names are
made names are made around to mean
danger made it doesn't matter what your
name is but Donna means nothing until
she goes and executes Google means
nothing until it becomes Google names
are [ __ ] made people spent 16 years
coming up with a [ __ ] name for their
business and zero days building their
[ __ ] business mmm-hmm give me a walk
but yes okay like I'm not judging people
enjoying the process coming name but the
reality is it doesn't matter
oh yeah soccer box all right like what
can you say how can I
yep you know I I'm just kidding yep the
happy people take me through it you
can't convince people like listen if
somebody who lived it you can't convince
people to take you serious you just
focus on the people that took you
serious mmm yeah
that's such good [ __ ] no that's that's
smart [ __ ] right you're not gonna
convince somebody who takes a 16 year
old what are you to say I'm older thank
you wish you were older when you're when
you're older you're gonna wish you were
younger bro I wish I was 16 I've run my
[ __ ] arms off to be 16 right now oh I
see no all I want to do do so many
things like I took a year of school
because of the internship thing and II
think I wake up with my age again I
still have it but I think it back to
obviously my turn something to do it and
we think that kicks my dad a bit too
it's been shooting has been reciting
about deepening ties and have to help
people kamikazes and I'm getting fill me
you know Legion all the stuff now I'm
kind of doing my business from the
ground up you know I love that and I am
half man could like a million there in
person I believe in me is my top and
that's all I need
why didn't you stay on a fight with
myself biggest actual knife bro yeah
yeah yeah be patient stay patient that's
the only thing I would tell you yeah
dude I'm gonna sit
I've almost lived three of your lives
[Music]
I'm awesome
all right okay thank you maybe sixteen
Danny
Tyler anything good there no right give
me one more soccer bucks
it's hard to pull right what's the best
card in the set who Santro he's legit
so Santro alive I like like signed
Sandra hello hello
alright hi this is Gary Vaynerchuk hey
what's up Gary
life is good bro how are you I'm doing
as well thanks for after what can I help
you with uh my man I actually just
started a new job recently had a
hospitality company they owned a steak
house destroyed a couple plays off
Birmingham and I was looking at empathy
wines I want to get in touch of the wine
director and try to get some empathy
into my store so it's pretty spot
couldn't find out on the website yeah
look maybe you could help with that yeah
email me at Gary at empathy wines calm
and I'll help you
we're about to open up on premise
opportunities we've done a little social
outreach and I would love for your help
thank you yeah thank you
anything I can answer for you uh
actually you know what I work with a
couple of mentors right now fitness base
working with Jordan and Mike right now
under out there that's awesome yeah so
they're they're really helped me right
now follow all your content putting all
your keys off into practice thank you
I'm really working on fine down the pipe
did they tell you all their success all
their success is attributable to me
biggis they gave 110% credit Beulah man
I appreciate you I just thought Jordan
George YouTube YouTube video about you
so oh great
awesome bro thank you so much for Cong
hey what is that thank you
Aubry Gary what up bro yo everything is
up right now oh my god I can't believe
you just called me bro
I had to yo what is going on bro I just
met Peter ah I've been I've been
watching you for like three years bro
likes you are literally like this big
brother father I've never had or humbled
thank you for now
it's crazy bro is crazy like this okay I
guess I got so many questions I can ask
you man but the most important question
is like I've done businesses online I
made money online like I do you preach
Facebook ads and I see you preach not to
give a [ __ ] about my anybody and I
definitely don't so like I guess the
main thing is like just people who on
the got you boy that why like while I've
got you I'm gonna use this as an
opportunity not giving a [ __ ] about when
anybody thinks means don't allow
anybody's judgment to disproportionately
penetrate your own but respect
respecting other people's feedback and
being thoughtful about it is incredibly
important so I don't give a [ __ ] about
what anybody thinks
yet I interact with people that are
trolling kind of negative to me because
I like understanding people's points of
view and I have that humility as well so
it's not just being so confident that
you don't give a [ __ ] it's also equally
being humble enough to be thoughtful
about hearing the bread back but it's
important to understand how to balance
those tones right I guess I just worded
it wrong to them no nobody no no you're
rewarding it right I'm saying it that
way and I'm taking advantage of this
moment to clarify it
gosh gosh it
yes I mean I guess the main thing is
like I really this is going to sound
very Kanye and arrogant like okay at the
end of the day you really like remind me
of myself okay because honestly bro I'm
just being real and like I have a single
mom right yep and it's just it's just me
and it's me and the dog and like and my
family and I take care of my mom my
grandma and it's just like it is me bro
so like I said [ __ ] school and I just
wanted to go all in I've been selling
shoes and like flipping stuff like going
out to like sneaker keep your releases
for in the clock in the morning like all
the [ __ ] that you preach I've done that
and you just like confirmed it like
seeing you document all this stuff you
just confirmed it bro like my mom is
like my biggest motivator bro
like she put me onto the garage sale
stuff and then when I found out about
you doing it like that just needed like
wow this is actually real so like I
guess the thing is what could I do to
like get back on my grind to how I was
because I was making a couple hundred
bucks
without even having to go into a job so
one like I feel like I didn't lock that
Drive why I don't know what's stopping
me bro like did you get soft no it's
like like literally I would oh did you
care what did you care what somebody
thought about it yeah well that's yes
they were good that's fine I mean I only
took everything I had in high school
once all the pretty girls in my high
school that were friends with me found
out I garage sales it took every ounce
of my uber self-confidence to persevere
and I barely persevered so I know the
average person struggles with it but I
still did it yeah I understand and I
think the main thing that stopping me
cuz like I even sold cars I bought and
flip car they go that's mine whatever
I'm crying what's the problem it fits
right tell me the truth I guess now you
stop it's okay you're a kid who made you
stop I mean I'm 27 years old
kid who made you stop well I was dating
this girl at this one time and it kind
of [ __ ] up everything just because of
life I guess I was distracted because of
what her family thought about me at the
time the end the end I know that was
that was cancelled in 2017 no no the end
that's what started the process what do
you mean it sounds like the reason you
stopped losing your way was you were
worried about the outside judgment of
your girlfriend's family and that's what
started you getting off that grind yeah
and it kind of gotten a little bit
bigger than that because it was like
from a small hometown and everybody kind
of knows each other and I'm like I know
you preached about like you know micro
influencers and like you know when you
handle a certain point of like people
starting to notice you like some people
take it to their head and I [ __ ] took
it to the head okay so you got gassed up
because people forgot super [ __ ]
gassed up because I actually I've met a
lot of different rappers and I did like
marketing I work for free for like a lot
of artists like a camp diary two kids
yeah a lot of different of Atlanta music
art yep I work for free for like two
years
okay that's because that was my main
passion I gotta add a lot of people
judge me from that point because like I
only knew like it was different it just
working a job what do they judge you for
saying you're getting suckered well just
because like I don't really see school
like the the only way to make money
that's fine psyche so one more time what
happened her her parents judged you and
said you should go to college and get a
real job yeah and I ended up doing that
and I went to I went yo yo man you
remember when you said you were like me
yeah you're not but that's okay cuz I'm
not special we're just different and you
need to understand that yeah and and
here's the good news you're 27
I got kind right man in a way that you
can't imagine and every second that you
spend on yesterday and how you got
[ __ ] up and gassed up and listen to
parents is every second that you're not
spending about tomorrow but it kind of
did it it kind of went to my peer groups
and and it didn't just go to his parents
and kind of went to my peer groups and
now it's like even like I used to
around a lot of people and like we
really group like and got really big in
our hometown and a lot of people started
to know my name and like we do business
online and things like that man my man
what you got gassed up in a small little
[ __ ] spot in Atlanta I'm getting I'm
[ __ ] blowing up in the world and I'm
not gassed up we're different
no I I actually got gassed up in Port
Saint Lucie Florida I don't come phone
yeah I know
what do you see [ __ ] Florida it's
middle of nowhere to get a whole town
hold on be careful now it seriously the
middle of nowhere so why didn't you
[ __ ] think that you were so [ __ ]
great when you were dominating port st.
Lucie where I think the [ __ ] Mets
play [ __ ] spring training because I
started here and I worked my way up I
guess I guess I just went backwards and
went all over the place I don't know man
but it's just crazy I don't even know
that phone with you it was just like I
actually went from 14 Lucy to
Tallahassee went to school and then I
drove from Tallahassee in my car landed
short drive left in my car multiple
nights just to go to a video shoot the
next day with like no money in my pocket
just a bit get back to my apartment and
go to school the next week okay stuff
like that
okay so it's like I was always just
chasing his dreams and not getting paid
for it but at the end of the day like
people didn't think how I thought about
like they were just like go to screwed I
had a job and like you know now I'm back
in in like South Florida back and forth
I'm not back in my hometown but I'm back
and forth and it's like it's just it's
just like I don't know how to get back
to get back to that grind like what I
have to do to start grabbing those shoes
and flipping those cars again because I
sold like 20 I feel like 24 cars in
three years
right and that was just me flipping them
on Craigslist flipping them on offer up
those at me I would buy the car cheapest
buck and then and fix it myself
yeah no you don't know you remember the
question I asked you first did you get
soft right that's the answer okay
I know I did no [ __ ]
yeah man
dude the only reason I'm getting right
now bro
I get it bro listen I understand like
you know might not resonate for John
because you're making a face but like
for you it's real because you actually
just realize something like I get it
like the single thing that people don't
understand is I've been doing the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm just doing exactly what
I did like the amount of logic that goes
into me coming back from where I just
was to this office tonight after I just
took the [ __ ] trip that I did I'm
[ __ ] exhausted like truly exhausted
like this was such a strategically smart
move to go home early tonight but I'm
like you know Memorial Day is coming so
I got that what did Alex say something
like like got it like it just right like
like I'm do I'm still doing it dude it's
10 p.m. I'm still doing it and I'm crazy
like I'm stand by everybody standards I
made it you know what I could have done
tonight do you know what I could've done
tonight you coulda done a lot of things
anything I wings the world whatever I
wanted I could be doing anything I
wanted that's what that's what's so
crazy bro like and what got me is like
what got me like bro I swear to nights
ago I was on YouTube
bro I watch yourself like it's my
religion you know they're like how you
say I watch it as much and go [ __ ]
sell something from Craigslist yeah yeah
bro people use me to feel like they're
doing something instead of doing
something but at the same time like it
was a different level man because like I
watched your interview and like the
thing that she did was nifty bro and in
like that right there like to see a man
living bro and that influence Oh light
and to have a conversation with you like
I would have asked you the same type of
things like and just to hear those like
to hear you and him go back and forth
bro like that was a dude that was just
here last month bro like just last month
and like just the things how he picked
up that dude at the coffee shop and like
those kinds of things those moments pros
like people people don't think those
kinds of things are real bro but like
it's just chance I left everything and
even when I do have money in school I
went up there to start you know doing
the marketing campaigns and doing the
South by Southwest Music Festival's with
these artists and stuff and I wasn't
getting paid [ __ ] I wasn't getting paid
anything but people are like Oh Audrey
this guy he's a you know he's just
around them you know he just surround
them he's not doing it but I was
offering from that was my dream Aubrey
you're you're you're living based on
other people's judgment no like okay
Doug
no [ __ ] it sucks bro why do you think
I'm spending my [ __ ] life trying to
make content to Pete get people to stop
doing it that's crazy
Aubrey I rang up my friends in my liquor
store in my when I was 20 I old it
you're 20 out how old are you 27 I said
20 in December I was 30
Bernie's young as [ __ ] bro the [ __ ]
the matter with you I'm 40 [ __ ] three
I'm cooler than you man any system
pressure the pressure is like you know
who supports my dreams and every
Stockton what do you mean supports
emotionally or financially no wait
emotionally so I good I wish you
supported financially so I know you
don't she's really all in like no you
don't know we don't want her to wish you
don't want her to support us financially
get back on your grind bruh I mean but
the thing is I could easily get back in
like it's not that [ __ ] you need to get
on my grind hard like a car like it's
just the initial like getting capital
disease things like that like bro how
much my money bro bro bro bro how much
money do you have right now negative how
much why
the audit yes what are we doing here are
we [ __ ] trying to do something good
are we gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] John are
you rest of our line
I mean I just paid my rent in my car bro
and like right now I'm just puzzling nah
bro I'm not gonna judge you I'm asking
you a basic question cuz I'm gonna help
you I don't give a [ __ ] if you say
negative 180 without no room you know me
people are in oh my god
bro I got like to be real bro we got
like no bro bro
sorry I got like 43 dollars in my wallet
well good news I know what to do with
$43 what do I got it youth you [ __ ]
know bro go to [ __ ] thrift store
tomorrow and turn 43 into 200 you know
what I mean it's not like I don't have
money coming in either bro bro probably
bring on Gumby right now I'm not an
opera I'm not I'm not judging I'm
telling you go on the offense okay but I
mean like I have stuff that's posted and
like what gets me [ __ ] up is like all
these kids and stuff like back when I
was reselling shoes it wasn't like that
like bro you go into a line and you
either go into a line with your boy you
have to make sure ticket copped him a
ticket to stand the line and hopefully
you get four pair deep but now dudes are
on line and they're like 13 years old
and they're flying massive amounts of
quality shoes and like I'm feeling like
that's the only way to make a profit and
and that's what I know that there's
lippisch you [ __ ] learn something
else
flip sports cards you're right I know
I'm right you're crying about yesterday
you sound like you sound like you're 72
in my day
it changed go figure out how to [ __ ]
write an algorithm then like what yeah
Brett yeah bro you got to change your
mindset bro I said you got to change the
mindset man you're looking backwards and
defense and why not instead of why yes
but really let me up for a couple of
years good
good news you're young as [ __ ] let's
unmess you up and stop looking backwards
fine we had two three years
sucked cool great now when you [ __ ]
taste beauty at 33 you'll be grateful
even more so because you knew how [ __ ]
shitty 25 to 27 was right and I'm being
a man I'm not asking I'm not asking for
anything I'm not doing anything at all
cuz I got money now and you know I tell
everybody if I'm not good today I'll be
good the next day so when everybody
asked me bro what I'm doing you're not
holding it bro
stop talking about everybody do you
don't even see dude you are so in it for
everybody else's opinion you everything
when you go watch this on youtube or
facebook all you're talking about is
everybody else's opinions I'm not
telling anybody anything I never told
anybody anything Wow what do you really
got I'm not worried about what anybody
thinks if I got it now if I don't have
it now if I used to have it now and I
did have it now and I'm gonna have it
exactly so what dude I don't give up I
don't know what you're saying every time
you're answering is you're living your
life based on other people's opinions
because that's become your new framework
yeah and that should burn me out bro
everybody that is the premaster years it
could burn me out so let's not do it
anymore
so let's not do it anymore yeah yeah I I
see what you're saying
do you I mean kind of it's just like the
time thing and like how you think you
got time and everything it's like I want
to do I want to pick right back off
where I was you can't you [ __ ] up oh
my god that's what I needed to hear good
so you saying I have to totally switch
up everything and just find something
new probably cuz you're super [ __ ]
salty and upset and [ __ ] up right this
second
you got it bro just cuz you were great
at flipping five years ago [ __ ] changed
it had it really had I'm sorry and
that's what happens to everybody guess
what
Kobe sad he's not playing basketball
right now damn it changed your dwelling
you're a [ __ ] dwelling machine if I
just didn't mean that girl I would
exceed the course I would have made like
you're just you're going you live in
[ __ ] you're living for yesterday my
sister should be sitting here second she
decided to live for tomorrow after 40
[ __ ] years
she got happy but she spent her whole
[ __ ] life for it about yesterday yeah
you know how you know how it works both
ways that's why I'm [ __ ] it's how I'm
humble and grounded this is how we're
different we're actually reverse bro
we're reverse because I don't give a
[ __ ] about yesterday meaning everything
I've done good everything I've done I'm
only as good as tomorrow it doesn't
matter what I've done if I make 37 bad
mistakes in a row over the next two
years
then I suck and yeah I was just watching
that video the other day he says like if
I say if I wanted to do something for
the next two years and I split it up six
months each like for the next few years
I could try something four times bro you
know how to sell you one God gifted you
yeah I really could tell it's no bother
Santa Claus well right now you were
[ __ ] up if you believe that because
you have $43 but I mean like then the
next day I'll have some more but nobody
buddy's not a great [ __ ] bass so what
I'm saying here as somebody who knows
how to sell you got to realize your
shits [ __ ] up and it's [ __ ] up
because you're looking backwards and
you're saying but it used to and they
don't get it and then the dead then your
do it now I brought a brand new 2017
like this and that kind of [ __ ] me up
the corset [ __ ] you up because you
worried about everybody of course you
were as soon as you were snowballing and
losing
money you went all in on the other way
Ollie I want as soon as you knew you
were [ __ ] uh-oh you're like now let
me over correct to [ __ ] create a
disguise to have [ __ ] up it's going be
really and that's the point where I am
now good right now good so now we're
gonna reverse it Wow that's what I need
to do
I didn't that's what I'm trying to do
can I give it can I give you a good can
I give you a real real real real real
good piece of advice I'm here writing it
down good write this down
go talk to the ten people closest to you
that you and tell them all the truths of
how [ __ ] up and how unhappy you are
and see how they react so you want me to
go tell the closest people I don't want
you telling every girl that you're
looking at every best homie that you've
been coming up with and tell me you
[ __ ] suck and you got nothing you got
43 dollars in the [ __ ] Lexus when the
[ __ ] with a [ __ ] no that's gone good
that's gone good are they believe that
good bro you need to [ __ ] on it who
you're hanging out with I did and I
chopped them all off bro and that was
only me let us go I told them all so
we're ready and like I'm at that point
now it's a reversal ass everybody last
thing we got it ready the last year you
there's only one person you got to chop
off left the 2005 to this second version
of you the 15 excuse me 2015 to today's
version of you that's the last person
you got to cut off and just start
something new around the thing you're
best at and this is this is like one
more thing man this is like one more
thing like you know how you saying I
gotta reverse it I get caught up because
like a lot of people the way that I was
moving back then of course because now
you know like I was just worried about
people's opinions really back then
Gordon like I went all in and spent a
whole bunch of money like I have a nice
apart like two months I did stupid
things for other people's judgments and
like but the time is like where I am now
I don't really care like I don't really
care about what people think in a sense
if they think that I'm like negative or
if they think that I'm like like I would
sure they're you've got no choice they
[ __ ] left want you to have the money
bro you live for other people
of course you're there now you have no
choice if you want to choices or these
people are broke
all those people still think on life
like you're saying to reverse it like
all those people even though like I am
where I am now I'm not I'm not where I
was back then but like if I were to go
to those people those 10 people if I
were to go to them like I don't look
down
they're not even around like I cut them
off because of the way that I was moving
back then I was like moving off of
jealousy and I was moving off of like
trying to like select my local people
and like now these I don't care about
none of that stuff like I click that
like since I got rid of that is City
apartment like I'm living within my
means for real now but you're like I
don't but regular you also just told me
12 minutes ago that you're not going
hard so you done something yeah that's
right I'm not going hard
you're so why cuz you're still depressed
from the yell that you took no I'm not
going as hard as I was because of those
people like all those people that if I
were to go and tell them like how [ __ ]
up it is now like all those people like
at office they won't hear me like that
because I really I really met up bro who
you bro you're living for other people
bro living in you some real good news
those 10 people nobody gives a [ __ ]
about yeah you're right I know I'm right
those 10 people you put on a pedestal
don't mean jack [ __ ] just like everybody
navigating through high school for the
coolest kids who don't mean dinner and
all these people on Facebook bro you're
still living for those 10 people just so
you know it just came out of your mouth
wait to watch the rewind in this and
some dumb never business online I have
over 800 people in my organization and I
mean we all are like 40
is it hard no [ __ ] it's hard it's hard
when you [ __ ] live your life for
other people which is why I'm really
trying to get people to not live their
life for other people I want to flow
with you for 2014 for minutes
I don't think I've spent 24 minutes with
teen garyvee this year it's the [ __ ]
truth yeah man I just I really just
wanna you know do like what you're doing
one day innit I mean not what you doing
you that you can I know what I'm doing
tomorrow I just wanna make like positive
light on to people well you're not going
to do that dr. WI secure [ __ ] on earth
worried about ten [ __ ] people from
Pensacola Florida because they don't see
me like that
I'm like bro you are so [ __ ] with
these ten people
I [ __ ] hate these 10 people the
[ __ ] the matter with you what I don't
give a [ __ ] how you're seen by them or
how they see you or how they don't hear
you
you're so sucked in to the [ __ ] of
yesterday and these ten people it's over
get the [ __ ] over it you cut them off at
an uni you cut them off because you took
the L you have no choice you're still
[ __ ] you didn't cut them off emotionally
no I did it's like you know a little bit
of that theme got to my head and I
started making a little bit of money on
Brian you didn't I mean you didn't have
money I did it but what I had was a
little bit of people and actually got to
my head and like Ken my local Kenneth
town yeah I was just like being an
arrogant ass bro and lies to ploy some
humility stop even neckla and that's
what I've been doing that's what I've
been doing though and that's what I'm
saying that's where I am now that was in
2015 okay and now if I start don't like
I've been on that gratitude is the
movement like all of that stuff that you
preached I'm on that and I've been on
that since like September last year and
it's just like now at this point to
where I am it's like I'm on the internet
and when I try and spread like a pond
message [ __ ] still that guy evil like
you're like we just because so because
you haven't made the video yet that
calls yourself out I get it no I did not
that's why bro the reason you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] you truly think I'm the evil guy
so [ __ ] make the video and tell
everybody that you were [ __ ] evil guy
from 2015 to 2017 and it [ __ ] brought
you to your [ __ ] knees
cuz you were a [ __ ] face and you
deserved it and now you're [ __ ]
changing and your extend you're grateful
that it took you to your knees and
you're excited for a new day and anybody
that comes in in fact about twenty
fourteen to seventeen I'm [ __ ] sorry
cuz I was a piece of [ __ ] but now I
don't want to be and I'm sorry and I
can't wait to look you in the face and
I'm sorry but you haven't done that yet
cuz you're not at the [ __ ] my house I
know you have it and I thought about
just like going on like my Facebook and
like recording a video and just like
tagging my friends do it like everybody
do it right now hang up make a video and
say you were [ __ ] [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] for five years and you [ __ ] up
and you lost your way and you were
insecure and you were broken and you
[ __ ] have been taken to your knees
and I'm never doing back there again I'm
gonna start all over and I'm gonna build
and that's what's up and if I see you in
the streets or in the club or somewhere
I'm gonna apologize your [ __ ] face
cuz of a big [ __ ] dick for a decade
or a half a decade and I thought about
doing that but you haven't because
they're scared cuz you saw what I need
with you that's what I need no [ __ ] put
your poison out the number one [ __ ]
thing that most people are watching this
right now half the new is [ __ ] share
their poison cuz the second they share
it they take control right now the
poisons got you it got me bro it got me
and I don't want that I wanna help
people
submit I don't share about the money for
every what's your [ __ ] last name
Medina what's that
Medina good Mei entertain Aubrey
Medina's a piece of [ __ ] from 2014 to
2018 spread it
and bro
yeah I'm not that way anymore bro I
believe you that's why I just did you a
favor
not right I believe you with my entire
heart which is why I just did you a
favor I'm really not bro
I believe you with my entire heart
that's why I just did you a favor
thank you welcome bro you got this bro
now you can't hide huh million people
gonna watch this now there's nowhere to
hide now just go be a good dude dude I
know you regret being a bad dude you
were a kid and had a room at work I know
bro why do you think I'm keeping you on
for 30 minutes people who wanted me to
hang out on you for wrong in 25 minutes
bro listen to me you were a [ __ ] kid
we all make mistakes you just have to
say you're sorry and that you're ashamed
and you're never gonna do it again so
you go like I do and I think you should
tag everybody and I think you should
tell real stories about how you [ __ ]
Punk that kid and stole that kid's money
and yelled at that girl and that's a
bigger amount like my Instagram is more
than watch me good so do it there bro do
what every winner dude you're scared
[ __ ] expose yourself get naked bro
yeah and that's the main thing bro I
just want all those people just not
looking in that light anymore exactly
which is why if they don't look at me in
that light bro I can walk outside it bro
just broke smell the air bro you have to
not look at yourself in that light first
by putting it out because I don't
personally like I don't personally but
they do and they think I'm in that brand
ring-tailed it because you haven't
[ __ ] said you're sorry you're [ __ ]
hiding like a little [ __ ]
yeah bro I know bro and it all started
there right your launches you're wrong
they're right you haven't put on weight
that way anymore
but you
and owned up to that [ __ ] bro have it
I know and good news the [ __ ] Twitter
everyone's posting right now Aubrey
Medina was a piece of [ __ ] from 2014 to
2017 you've got nowhere to hide anymore
you're good
you're free now go [ __ ] put it on
Instagram go make a [ __ ] video right
now one minute tag everybody and it's
over your poison will only no more I
don't want that girl I don't want that
so post so post you will literally have
to dislike record a video and dip like
the toe people like to straight up like
yes I'm sorry because I thought about
making yes a video like that yes you
have to do it now everybody who's
watching do me a favor da on Twitter the
really have a big following
I don't get you brother really
listen to me listen to me and listen to
me good make the [ __ ] video right now
cuz cuz if you don't you'll be stuck
forever Oh what are you scared of
telling the world you lost you just did
more people heard this than your [ __ ]
Instagram it already happened
what do you baby Medina what's your
what's your Twitter Audrey - oh gee I'm
sorry on Instagram
Aubrey the og that or duh duh you gotta
give it what that like TG yeah
tae AUV are you ITA EOG tha yeah right
if some sort of dollar sign s e-g [ __ ]
[ __ ] thing or something my logo yet
hey you got to write the person yeah man
like I honestly just like a changed man
like I'm not like that
nowadays everybody that I'm hungry I
believe you nobody else does because you
haven't [ __ ] owned it you know I'm
saying yeah I see what you're saying
you're talking about plant food down
yeah I was actually a vegetarian for
seven years and my mom put me onto that
and I just recently got back on that so
I'm trying this bedspread like health
stuff to people and I've been juicing
and just trying to tell people about
that I like your face I'm serious by the
way they're welcome Audrey listen to me
you got this bro just make the [ __ ]
video they don't need bro can I tell you
a secret that's gonna [ __ ] blow your
face off Myrtle I'm ready bro I'm ready
for whatever whatever people think I'm
right here you're with us people don't
give a [ __ ] as much as you think they
got their own problems you know yeah and
I realized that broke because I when I
had that car I brought that car
brand-new and it wasn't cheap you know
what I mean it was brand-new
and like I literally just like I got
that card just because like I could do
it and I just like just in it just
because I've always sold cars like I
told you like I was flipping cars and
stuff like that and I'm just used to a
certain lifestyle so I felt like let me
do let me just buy this car here and you
know people are doubting me they think I
can't do it anyways so let me do it and
then I did it and I was just like you
know a couple of years later like four
why did I even [ __ ] do this I I was
flipping cars because I didn't even want
to have to have a car payment bro
looking to me it's time make the video
it's time bro you can't [ __ ] post
being grateful is contagious and all
this nice [ __ ] on your [ __ ] gram and
live now overall I like you you know
what else you know what you really feel
way more than [ __ ] gratitude you feel
[ __ ] you feel you feel you feel upset
about what you did you feel you feel
obligated yeah I know you do bro
what you think a [ __ ] waste in like
35 minutes here with you you're a good
kid you just had a bad era go [ __ ]
tell the world [ __ ] Frank bro even
when I was doing you pick those friends
dick face it's time for you to [ __ ]
take accountability i i heard bad
friends cuz you were bad yeah man I'm
gonna do this [ __ ] I didn't have bad
friends us being so the same do you
think I just like make up one minute
long video yes yes I do right the [ __ ]
now
and it title it like I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry and then [ __ ] get way off
whenever you can in the video and then
write more in whatever you couldn't
finish off and [ __ ] tag Karen and
Jamal and Rick and [ __ ] uncle Charlie
and [ __ ] tag them all and [ __ ] say
it and live your [ __ ] life bro
everybody sucks everybody makes mistakes
you're a good kid you had a bad era fix
it very that yeah great very bad good
news people do way worse people murder
you're fine you were a dick face good
let's get over it let's move yeah well I
need to get on that [ __ ]
you're still it's but you're not willing
to be a man right now you're scared so
you think if I just post a video like
yeah change it will change your life yes
I do and more importantly yes because
you have to change your opinion I got to
get you off of worrying about those ten
people you have to start with you it
will change you for you and then
whatever happens with those ten will
happen based on
they're at in life too are in a good
place they'll give you hope
all these people are telling me to meet
this video okay all right good
see ya